اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من نابلس اهلا بكم
تنفيذ اول صفقه تبادل بين حماس واسرائيل
في اطار اتفاق الهدنه المؤقته الاحتلال
يفرج عن 39 طفلا وامراه من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين وكتائب القسام تسلم 24 محتجزا
بينهم عمال تايلندي في حين قالت الخارجيه
القطريه ان الافراج عن التايلنديين جاء
خارج اطار اتفاق الهدنه بينما اكد التل
ابيب ان المحتجزين المفرج عنهم وصلوا الى
اسرائيل مع دخول اتفاق الهدنه المؤقته في
قطاع غزه حيز التنفيذ بدء دخول المساعدات
وخروج الجرحى عبر معبر رفح في حين اطلق
الجيش الاسرائيلي النار على نازحين حاولوا
العوده الى منازلهم في مدينه غزه ما ادى
الى استشهاد فلسطينيين واصابه اخرين بينما
اكد هنيه ان حماس ملتزمه بتنفيذ الاتفاق
الذي الزم به اسرائيل ولن تتخلى عن
مسؤوليتها تجاه الشعب
الفلسطيني قوات الاحتلال تنسحب من مستشفى
الشفاء وتفجر مرافقه قبل الانسحاب وسط
مناشدات لنقل الجرحى والمصابين الى
مستشفيات اخرى في حين قالت الصحه العالميه
انها تعمل على تنفيذ مزيد من عمليات
الاجلاء من مستشفيات غزه في اقرب وقت
بينما اكدت منظمه اطفال الحرب ان الهدنه
لا تكفي للوصول لاكثر من طفل بحاجه
للمساعده وزير الخارجيه الايراني يامل ان
تكون الهدنه بدايه لوقف جرائم الكيان
الصهيوني من جهته اكد الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي ان الاولويه هي لاحتواء
التصعيد وتوفير مساعدات لقطاع غزه وقال
وزير خارجيه تركيا ان بلاده تعمل على وقف
اطلاق نار مستمر مؤكدا على ضروره تطبيق حل
دولتين اما سوناك فقد اكد ان الهدنه امر
بالغ الاهميه لانهاء محنه الرهائن وتوصيل
المساعدات الانسانيه للقطاع الى
اللقاء